the water has risen dramatically
overnight you can see bus shelters which
are virtually up to the roof a lot of
people who thought they were safe
because the water was so low yesterday
have woken up this morning and found
that they are
covered and surrounded by water they
might have lived on the second or the
third floor and now they're finding
they're at risk so that is what the
rescuers are doing now trying to go to
all of these places find out at this
stranded old people who are trapped
inside and we've seen that these two
coming out with wheelchairs in boats
with their wheelchairs some people have
actually managed to make it from
russian-controlled territory and talk
about being bombed and shelled on the
beach as they're trying to leave and
Russian troops trying to steal their
boats
[Music]